تنزل [موسيقى]
هنا وتحاول العثور على الحياة
في أحد أكثر الأماكن قسوة
في العالم ، فإنه لا يمكن وصفها
بالتعمق في
قلب النهر الجليدي
، مما يجعلك معرضًا للخطر للغاية مع العلم
أن الجدران يمكن أن تنهار في الواقع في
النهر الجليدي.  خاصة به
وأنت تحت رحمة النهر الجليدي ،
هناك عدد قليل جدًا من الكائنات الحية التي يمكنها في
الواقع تحمل مكان مثل هذا
التنين دي لا باتاغونيا يفعل ذلك
تطوريًا حيث تكيف نفسه
للعيش في هذا الحد الأقصى ،
هناك القليل جدًا من المعلومات
حول الأنواع
ولكن هذا هو  مهددة بالانقراض لأننا نعلم بالفعل
أن موطنها
يذوب ، وتختفي الأنهار الجليدية ،
وستختفي الأنواع ، ويكاد يكون محكومًا بالفناء
إذا لم نفعل شيئًا حيال ذلك ، انظر
إلى هذا أمر مدهش
حماية الأنواع التي يمكن أن
تعلمك بالفعل كيفية البقاء على قيد الحياة
بيئة مثل هذه على مدار العام
لملايين السنين ما لا
تعيشه أي فقاريات أخرى فعليًا ، من
الضروري أن نعمل ضد عقارب الساعة من أجل
حاول الحفاظ على الأنواع ، حاول أن
تفهم أنك تحاول اكتساب أكبر قدر
من المعرفة من الأنواع قبل أن
تختفي ،
لقد أذهلتني حقيقة أنه
لا يوجد أي شخص آخر هنا ولكن كلما زاد الوقت الذي
أمضيته في العيون غير مريح ،
شعرت بالرضا أكثر
بمعرفة  أنني أقضي وقتًا طويلاً
قدر الإمكان لفهم الأنواع
التي لا بد أن تختفي
[موسيقى]